Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
With this technique, we can take a photograph
of a desired material, and use a neural network
to create a digital material model that matches
it that we can use in computer games and animation
movies.
We can import real world materials in our
virtual worlds, if you will.
Typically, to do this, an earlier work required
two photographs, one with flash, and one without
to get enough information about the reflectance
properties of the material.
Then, a followup AI paper was able to do this
from only one image.
It doesn't even need to turn the camera around
the material to see how it handles reflections,
but can learn all of these material properties
from only one image.
Isn't that miraculous?
We talked about this work in more detail in
Two Minute Papers episode 88, that was about
two years ago, I put a link to it in the video
description.
Let's look at some results with this new technique!
Here you see the photos of the input materials
and on the right, the reconstructed material.
Please note that this reconstruction means
that the neural network predicts the physical
properties of the material, which are then
passed to a light simulation program.
So on the left, you see reality, and on the
right, the prediction plus simulation results
under a moving point light.
It works like magic.
Love it.
As you see in the comparisons here, it produces
results that are closer to the ground truth
than previous techniques.
So what is the difference?
This method is designed in a way that enables
us to create a larger training set for more
accurate results.
As you know, with learning algorithms, we
are always looking for more and more training
data.
Also, it uses two neural networks instead
of one, where one of them looks at local nearby
features in the input, and the other one runs
in parallel and ensures that the material
that is created is also globally correct.
Note that there are some highly scattering
materials that this method doesn't support,
for example, fabrics or human skin.
But since producing these materials in a digital
world takes quite a bit of time and expertise,
this will be a godsend for the video games
and animation movies of the future.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!